ländern das nimmt ja immer absurdere
form an aber jetzt stehen sogar
wissenschaftler bei ard und zdf dagegen
auf sie vor den schluss mit dieser
gender sprache dort bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen im tv
das weitaus weniger riskant für deutsche
steuerzahler innen steuergelder das
hätte jetzt auch von ihnen
ja ja das klappt bei dem einen schon
ganz gut oder wie hier bei bundeskanzler
olaf scholz weniger gut vor jedem und
für jeden jeder die bürgerinnen und
bürger eine entlastung bekommen finde
aber dass wir schon sehr sehr viele
bürgerinnen bürger geimpft haben
generell spaltet die gender debatte die
gesellschaft die befürworter sagen
gendern sei ein muss und nur so fühlen
sich alle in der gesellschaft akzeptiert
und auch der öffentlich-rechtliche
rundfunk setzt auf sendern die meisten
anderen in unserer gesellschaft finden
es einfach nur quatsch genau wie auch
mehr als 100 linguisten und
organisationen jetzt einen aufruf gegen
die gender sprach im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk unterzeichnet haben
sie fordern damit ein ende des gender
wahnsinns
darüber müssen wir sprechen uns mit
unserem bild politik reporter sebastian
geisler hier bei uns im studio schön es
hier ist getrieben wird was ist da los
ja das ist jetzt also mittlerweile schon
über 90 wissenschaftler die aufstehen
gegen das gender möglichen rechtlichen
aus einer reihe von gründen sie sagen
das lässt sich aus der sprache heraus
aus der grammatik nicht begründen diese
kunstsprache von der sie auch sprechen
sie sagen es spricht eigentlich
entspricht nicht dem programm auftrag
der öffentlich-rechtlichen uns eine
gender sprache an zu erziehen und sie
sagen sogar dass die
öffentlich-rechtlichen wenn sie selbst
über das phänomen ländern berichten
nicht neutral berichten sondern sich
dann teilweise einzelne aktivisten
ranholen auch aus der wissenschaft die
so tun als gäbe es da so in
wissenschaftlichen konsens dafür sie
sage aber nein diesen wissenschaftlichen
konsens gibt es eben nicht und deswegen
machen sie jetzt auch diesen aufruf und
sagen nein die wissenschaftler sind auch
da das ist hoch kontrovers es gibt
keinen sozusagen pro ländern in der
wissenschaft darum geht es diesen leuten
kann man das rad aber wieder
zurückdrehen also das ist ja jetzt die
frage anhand dieses aufrufs wird diese
aufrufe erfolg haben wird der widerstand
erfolg haben oder wird eben einfach
weiter geändert und dass es nicht mehr
aufzuhalten also ich glaube einer
samstag formiert sich so ein bisschen
war es da gibt's jetzt widerstand da
sind leute auch aufgewacht und sagen na
ja ein wenig jetzt mal dagegen halten
und sagen wir lehnen das aber ab dann
setzten sich eben die gender aktivisten
damit durch zum einen zum anderen habe
ich aber mal angefragt bei ard und zdf
wie sieht es denn aus jetzt gibt's
diesen aufruf wollt ihr vielleicht jetzt
aufhören mit dem gender nah dieses zum
beispiel vom zdf nein wir stellen es
unseren moderatoren weiterhin frei zu
gendern also offensichtlich ist es dann
egal auch dass rund 80 prozent der
gebührenzahler auch sagen wir möchten
das eigentlich so mich haben in unseren
sendungen jetzt bereits irgendeine
reaktion seitens der wissenschaft sind
weitere aktionen aufrufe geplant um auf
dieses thema weiter aufmerksam zu machen
oder ist das jetzt eine debatte die im
sande verläuft wir machen so weiter wir
haben euch nicht fertig aus bei der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk braucht
ja auch sozusagen seine legitimation
dass er auch seine gebühren von uns
allen einzieht wenn natürlich 80 prozent
der menschen eigentlich gegen das
ländern sind ist schon die frage wie
kann das eigentlich sein es schließen
sich jetzt immer mehr wissenschaftler
diesem aufruf an mal sehen dass gewinnt
jetzt gerade ein bisschen an fahrt die
ganze nummer insofern vielleicht bewirkt
es tatsächlich was dank an unser bild
reporter bildpolitik reporter sebastian
geist oder zum ländern im öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen ard und zdf danke
dir
[Musik]